this is my hypothesis isaac netro
traveled to the dark continent there he
met don freaks on the shoreline of lake
mobius netro then returned to the human
realm with the first half of don's book
journey to the new world naturo then
gave a copy of that book to jing freaks
which started his obsession with the
dark continent while zigzaldik stayed
behind to travel with don that's my
thinking now let's see if it works hello
and welcome to the new world review
source for everything anime and manga
and today we're here to discuss quite
possibly the only successful return
journey to the dark continent that we
know of being the netro expedition and
we're doing this because i was posed an
intriguing question by a user named
raging miku who inquired as to whether
or not zigzaldik a member of this
expedition was still alive because there
is some very interesting information to
suggest that he may have actually died
however as i looked further into it a
much bigger picture started to unravel
threatening to provide potential answers
to many of our lingering questions so i
think it's about time that we examined
the mysteries behind the netero voyage
and it's all going to begin with a quick
round of net row or netta no a very
simple minigame the rules of which are
as follows i am going to ask you a
multiple choice trivia question about
our former chairman and should you
answer incorrectly then your punishment
will be to subscribe to the new world
review which will result in consistent
injections of hunt-based content
administered directly into your youtube
feed meanwhile if you are correct then
you will be awarded with a slap on the
butt from the 100 type guanine
bodhisattva so here is our trivia
question how old was netro when he began
training in the mountains a 45 b 46 or c
47 all fairly reasonable sounding
midlife states being so please do make
your choice now and we shall reveal the
answer in 3 2 1 and bam it was b 46
years old so if you guessed incorrectly
then you know the thing to do and please
do say hi in the comments below if you
are new to our association welcome but
let's begin with the official story
here's a guy his name is steiner and he
is important because he is a powerful
bureaucrat within the ipa an
organization which is designed to
regulate travel to and from the dark
continent in a very short amount of time
steiner has become one of the world's
foremost authorities on the dark
continent due primarily to having read a
very fun book called journey to the new
world east edition which was of course
penned by the almost mythical figure of
don freaks in addition to this diner has
information on all officially recorded
human journeys to the dark continent
which according to him come to a grand
total of
149 ventures of those 149 only five
expeditions had people returned from the
continent which assumes that the other
144 had a 100 casualty rate now of the
five voyages which did see individuals
return there were only 28 survivors in
total and of those 28 only three of them
were able to reintegrate into society
and according to official statistics
that would be a survival rate of 0.04
fairly terrifying but i bring this up
because the number three gets speculated
on here and there for being a bit
awkward primarily because three is not
four and four is the number of
characters we know of who have visited
the continent and potentially returned
so we have isaac natural the neo dove
zigzaldik and of course beyond neterror
and given that we know for a fact that
netro linnet and beyond all returned it
can be easy at face value to assign zig
with a rather unfortunate fate because
he is the fourth known character of a
maximum of three confirmed survivors but
what does get missed quite a bit is that
steiner also states that of those three
beyond is the only one alive today which
more or less confirms that steiner is
unaware of netro's unofficial journey
because sure netro is now dead however
lynnea is still alive and well so it
should be at least two survivors if they
were factored in so luckily for zigg
this gives him a lot of potential to you
know not be dead to complicate matters
though this is another thing that often
gets overlooked but natara actually set
foot on the dark continent twice
according to him one of these occasions
is the unofficial voyage that we are
exploring in this video but the other is
completely unknown it's almost certainly
another sneaky unofficial trip because
the voyagers with survivors that we know
of were all conducted by the v5 nations
who did so without informing the hunter
association very sneaky of them but
meaning that netaro likely would have
had no involvement with them but the
most interesting thing steiner says is
that mankind has never succeeded at
making a round trip but then he has this
brief inner thought where he thinks to
himself not officially implying that he
may have knowledge of some unofficial
journeys or just showing us that steiner
has a healthy dose of skepticism about
him realizing all of the potential
faults in officially collated knowledge
and one question that steiner may have
failed to ask at this point is where did
their dark continent knowledge come from
who published journey to the new world
because it was written by don frixius
but it was clearly not published or
distributed by him so that leaves us
with a mystery publisher which leads us
quite nicely now into jing freaks jing
is a unique man for about a billion
different reasons however on this
occasion he possesses some pretty insane
knowledge in fact it's only because of
jing that we even know about netro's
voyage to begin with jing dropped that
massive nugget when he was explaining
the dangers of the dark continent to
beyond's expedition team and this is
pretty huge because you need to ask why
jing and you can't say that sure he knew
because he was a zodiac in the hunter
association and they have all kinds of
special knowledge of netero's stuffery
because they don't or they do but not so
much on this jing is the only one who
knew because weirdly enough some of the
zodiacs didn't even know that the dark
continent existed and even the one who
had the most intimate knowledge of it
paristan was himself unaware of netaro's
journey so for whatever reason jing
freaks was entrusted with this knowledge
something that netro clearly had no
inclination of giving up on a whim and
we know that it was netro who told jing
directly because jing even quotes the
former chairman's words which were this
place is too big it's off the charts and
this decision to tell jing and jing
alone is why i propose that on netaro's
unofficial voyage that he may have
encountered don freaks now it's hard to
put a timeline on exactly when netro
visited the dark continent however
judging by his hair length and general
aesthetic presentation as well as
netaro's own words that he visited the
continent when he was quite young this
would imply that netro visited prior to
his training in the mountains at the age
of 46 which is actually a pretty massive
thing to point out because now we're
talking about netro before he achieved
his enlightened god mode nenabilities he
was still likely quite powerful but
nowhere near the incarnation of him that
we're familiar with and perhaps visiting
the continent is what prompted netro to
take some time to reflect in the human
world that doesn't necessarily matter
though because we do know for a fact
that don would have been on the dark
continent at the same time as netro's
group because he initially set out to
explore the land mass roughly 300 years
ago and now i think the hurdle that may
come up in this discussion is well how
did they encounter each other it's hard
to pin down but don may have literally
had a couple of centuries of head start
on netro exploring the continent so
there's no way they could have met yeah
well no in fact not here in fact no the
hundreds of years of expiration thing
may be true but we also need to keep don
freak's mission in mind he did not set
out to explore the depths of the dark
continent his goal was to spend his life
traveling the shoreline of lake mobius
and logging his experiences so look it's
all about chance here but at any given
time over the last 300 years don freaks
was theoretically reachable depending on
which part of the human world you set
out from and which part of the continent
you landed on so my proposal is that
nataro and his party happened to land on
a piece of shoreline very close to where
don was currently traveling which may
actually explain quite a bit for example
how did netaro survive the dark
continent given that he was more of a
sprightly young brat at the time there
was a very real risk of death and
stumbling across don a man who was very
well versed in dark continent survival
may very well have saved his life and
not only that but extended his life
because one thing here prior to his
death netaro was at least 110 years old
he emphasized the whole elise thing
because it's implied that he was almost
certainly way way way older but even the
baseline of 110 is insane because humans
in hunter hunter follow a more real
world life expectancy take zeno zoldick
for example he's only 67 and he looks
even older than netro did at at least
twice his age now don freaks did find an
answer to this whole aging problem which
was the substance of nitro rice a food
item on the dark continent that extends
one's life which was logged in his
journal and it actually inspired one of
the official voyages to embark and find
it although they did fail they failed
catastrophically and it seems very
unlikely that netro and his group would
have just stumbled upon the substance by
sherlock but if don were to have shared
some of his already gathered nitro rice
then it would explain why both netro and
lynnae have lived the absurdly long
lives they have that or scenarios could
get slightly more complicated for
example netro meets don on the first
voyage loans of the rice and then sets
out on a second expedition to acquire it
that's one of a ton of possible
different scenarios but the thing i keep
coming back to is how the writing of don
freaks returned to the human world it's
been said that journey to the new world
east edition was published quote several
centuries ago which is very vague but
then again so is netero's age i mean
given that he was known to fight against
xenozoldic's grandfather maha it's
impossible to tell just how long this
man may have existed which is why i
think it's entirely possible that netro
met don freaks on the dark continent and
was entrusted with delivering the first
half of his book to humanity which would
have been in etro's best interest
because he was the one who seriously
pushed for travel to the dark continent
to be forbidden so this book would have
served as a fine warning to most not to
risk opening pandora's box however it
also goes on to reinforce the jin
connection however many years back
decades maybe even centuries later this
bright young go-getter by the name of
jing freaks took the hunter exam and was
the only one of his year to pass jing
has a demonstrated interest in
archaeology and human history and
recognizing that delicious freak's
lineage isaac naturo decided to tell him
about at least one of his dark continent
expeditions and may have even piqued his
interest by pointing him in the
direction of don's book and then you
know what a whole generation later netro
would encounter yet another freaks by
the name of gone a child which he took
an unusual interest in although when
you've already met two exceptional
members of the freak's clan i'm sure
that gone's potential would have been
very easy to see especially when
accompanied by a zoldick a family with
whom netro seems to share an even deeper
history which actually leads us back to
z he still has a big question mark over
his head with a few potential solutions
one thought we do need to establish is
that zig and mahazaldik may be the same
person i'm not going to go into huge
detail about this because i have a whole
different video exploring that topic but
it is a fairly solid evidence-backed
thought another possibility is that just
as suggested by the person who inspired
this video zigzaldik may be dead given
netaro's apparent inexperience when he
landed on the dark continent with zigg
and lanae a casualty would have not at
all been unexpected zigg could have died
and that may even be a reason for maha
zaldik to fight netro as an endeavor of
familial revenge but the third and most
outlandish possibility is that for
whatever reason zig may have chosen to
stay on the dark continent and travel
with don freaks and i'm not gonna lie i
like this idea primarily because it
would involve forging another freak
sodic duo and really wrapping up hunter
hunter in a nice neat little narrative
package but it is 100 pure speculation
there's just something very appealing to
me about netro leaving the dark
continent with his last image being of a
freaks and azoldik standing side by side
then potentially centuries later during
the 287th hunter exam in comes gone
freaks and killer zoldick causing a wave
of untold nostalgia with a netro and
hence why he took such a strong interest
in both of them even to the point where
he allowed them both to participate in
the chimera ant mission the question is
would togashi do such a thing and
honestly i'm not so sure hunter hunter
doesn't usually end up being that neat
and or satisfying however togashi was
really laying some very nice foundations
with this whole dark continent business
and i can only hope that we get to
explore the deeper story of these
characters in the future but to explore
some more here is another video it's
about hunters and hunting which is that
thing that you like because there's
always more to learn explore and
experience with this wonderful series so
i look forward to seeing you there